so bioinformatics for infectious
diseases
is really a program designed to address
the pressing need to understand
characterize monitor and address by
intervention the infectious diseases
that are so prevalent and are
characterizing this 21st or 20th uh yeah
21st century so in this program we'll
talk about how to apply data analysis
tools and a lot of them are going to be
somewhat similar to each other but
applied in very different types of
outbreaks epidemics coronavirus ebola
virus rhinovirus tuberculosis malaria so
different types of viral bacterial and
other pathogenic diseases
the program is really designed in a
similar fashion uh you will explore
relevant topics tools methods data
repositories project examples and you'll
be able to see how multi-omics analysis
analysis of genomic transcriptomic
proteomic data is going to inform
different types of decisions about
outbreaks
before we jump into this let's briefly
talk about what is
the definition of infectious diseases so
infectious diseases also called
communicable diseases are called by a
pathogen and that pathogen can be a
bacteria virus parasite or fungi and
these kinds of diseases are different
from non-infectious diseases or what's
commonly known as chronic diseases
and so we will actually talk about
specific applications of bioinformatics
to the study of infectious diseases
now in the last couple of years all of
us have been
focused on covid19 and i think really as
a result we kind of
see infectious diseases primarily caused
by viruses but in reality they could be
caused by different types of pathogens
including bacteria that can colonize and
kind of subdue different types of
functions that are important but also
can release toxins and cause organ
failure so in the recent years there
have been a number of pathogens like the
ebola virus in 2014 the outbreak that
brought to the forefront genomic
surveillance of epidemic outbreaks
there have been diseases that have been
affecting millions and millions of
people
and we see
that these diseases actually are not
just the ones that are new like novel
coronavirus but there have been for
centuries like malaria and malaria
affects
a a huge amount of people and has been
for many many decades or even centuries
novel
diseases caused by the coronavirus or by
re-emergence of specific diseases are
going to continue and be
you know very important and dangerous
situations that we'll have to address
using such tools now importantly these
kinds of outbreaks are only one type
they are kind of silent and then all of
a sudden there's an outbreak but there
are many viruses that cause or lead to
chronic diseases and so even though we
kind of tend to separate these two
categories there is a quite large
overlap for example epstein-barr virus
and other types of
viruses can lead to cancer
so
in addition to that right beyond viruses
there is a whole field studying
different types of bacteria and for
example uh drug resistance uh microbial
or resistant to antibiotics is a huge
concern and so in this program we're
going to talk about examples in all of
these different fields and importantly
we will also talk about the response to
these diseases that our body already
possesses and how different types of
treatments like vaccines are leveraged
to actually enhance this kind of a
response
so
when we look at the history of
infectious diseases and we look at the
methods to control such outbreaks you
will be surprised to find that actually
vaccines that we talked so much about
today are not not the only ones that
were
responsible for the reduced load of
infectious diseases on the population so
from population health perspective we
can see that the establishment of health
departments
actually
municipal use of chlorine and water
use of penicillin
are all
precessors of the vaccines which was
introduced in the 1950s and up until
today
those methods were actually very very
effective
however what happened just recently is
all of a sudden
after having such success with methods
that we already discussed covid19 has
surpassed the mortality of even such
diseases like cancer
and so on one hand we have this dynamic
where we have effective measures that
are quite simple
just washing your hands having chlorine
and water having availability of
antibiotics and then all of a sudden we
see this tremendous
growth of mortality caused by a virus a
virus that has already been studied and
so that leads us to the significance and
the impact of bioinformatics
so in the era of covet 19
not only were we able to analyze that
data quite uh rapidly but very quickly
we were able to identify a specific
pathogen that then was tracked almost in
real time to understand how it changes
how it evolves how it starts infecting
more and more people and starting to ask
important questions and the ability to
ask those questions using data that was
collected is the essence of
bioinformatics what is bioinformatics
bioinformatics allows us to leverage
these data sets that have been collected
ask specific questions and get to a
practical interpretation so that we
understand something and we're able to
make conclusions
now importantly this pandemic has opened
a
number of new questions that are now
being asked and we will see how those
questions are being asked by researchers
that have
the expertise to design experiments or
to leverage data that was collected from
others
so here's an example an example where we
can see that we can not only detect a
specific strain of a virus but we can
actually track it over time and
important questions will start to emerge
what is the long-term consequences of
covet-19 how do we monitor and prevent
outbreaks of these infections how do we
leverage our detailed genomic
characterization of the virus or the
pathogen and introduce a very specific
targeted therapy that can prevent or
kind of make it less dangerous
so with this brief introduction i will
again pass on the stage to dr raghav to
speak about the specifics and examples
that are relevant for this upcoming
program
and
answer any questions that you might have
about what are the outcomes of such
training so over to you dr raghav